je suis ici pour le globe j'écris un
article sur l'opération goliath vous
avez le choix de me dire ce qui s'est
vraiment passé ou alors vous pouvez
gaspiller cette précieuse opportunité
je ferais bien attention avant
d'imprimer quoi que ce soit en rapport
avec cette affaire sinon quoi je ne
voudrais pas vous glisse
cette opération est un scandale national
la police canadienne semble avoir des
strapontins
de quoi mon ouïe on ne peut pas publier
cet article ça pourrait nous revenir en
pleine forme je vais écrire mon [ __ ]
d'articles tu peux le mettre en première
page au nom c'est évident like you
[Applaudissements]
tu penses pas qu'il est temps de laisser
tomber non je m'appelle
- thierry sert tout ça pour ça
si jamais ce qui s'est passé ici été
rendu
oui
le canadien patrick chan
rien faire pour empêcher sa tortue peut
pas sauver les rues
[Musique]
demande à vendredi
je voudrais que je fasse quoi que je
laisse pourrir en payant
[Musique]